today's topic my wife aborted her baby
over astrology this is a story someone
sent me i have no idea what it reads
so i figured i would just take a shot
and i will read it in front of you guys
so why i've got an abortion because the
child would be a sagittarius i'm upset
because we're trying for a child
my wife and i have been married for
about three years and we were thinking
of starting a family
fertility issues run on both sides of
the family so we're pretty surprised to
find out
because we weren't exactly trying it was
one of those if it happens it happens
type of situations
the baby would have been due in december
my wife is really into astrology tarot
cards and that sort of thing
i know reddit has a hate boner for
astrology but i see it as no different
than a love of cars
oh no she knows i'm not into it up until
now it hasn't been a big deal in our
relationship
when we first had that maybe we should
have a baby talk she started to get a
little more interested in astrology
which didn't strike me as odd
what struck me as odd was her reaction
to finding out when we talked about
having a baby she was super duper
excited pushing for us to get pregnant
sooner rather than later but she seemed
kind of scared when she saw the results
of the first test that was in late april
her parents got into an accident in may
needed help getting around so she moved
in with them for a few weeks
during that time she barely called or
texted me that isn't completely out of
the norm but i felt like she would
be commuting more since she was pregnant
at this point she was showing
to me she didn't look super pregnant but
i noticed a difference
she came back three days later and she
looked like she had lost weight she
barely talked to me and looked extremely
on edge
so finally i got her to talk to me she
just blurts out i aborted the baby
i was at a loss for words i was just
staring at her
she was trying to play some sick choke
on me and she went out to see if she
felt the baby was going to be a
sagittarius
and she doesn't feel that her sign
sunset isn't compatible
or not a good fit for a mother child
[Music]
bond
so i screamed at her i said nasty things
she said nasty things back you told me
was because it was her body and her
choice and she's right
but i don't get to feel bad too i'm
sleeping on the couch right now i'm
trying to figure out my life for me
what do you think this video is not
going to be long
grab your [ __ ] and leave this girl was
so prejudiced
against mumbo jumbo children
that she aborted one
that is not the person i want to be with
that's going to take that decision
like that for that reason
like that's your reason that's going to
be who i'm going to try to raise
kids with that's who to me
what she just did there to me is the
same thing
as someone disowning their children
because they're gay
the bible says so i'm gonna do that
astrology says that we're not compatible
so i'm not gonna do that we're not
compatible you have to you you
we we can't go what you're doing is yo
to me
i get it yeah to you it's not yeah sure
but to me
that's in the same ammo that's the same
thing wow
wow for me it's not the same thing but
we all know the astrology point
is stupid so i'm not going to spend a
long time talking about that
but i do think it's interesting here yes
it's your body it's your choice
but i think when you're in a committed
relationship with someone and you guys
are trying to vie for children
the fact that you don't have their
consideration
of your partner when you're making that
choice to me is unbelievably selfish
it's self-centered and it's not
something i'd ever respect in somebody
of course listen i'm pro-choice a lot of
people are going to get mad about that
say whatever you want that's your
opinion we disagree blah blah blah
but i think we can all agree the bare
minimum
let you talk to your partner before you
make that choice
because while it's your body it's your
choice that choice that you're making or
choosing not to make
that's gonna have a tremendous impact on
that person's life
tremendous yes it impacts you but it
also impacts them
so while they may not be able to choose
a conversation would be the bare minimum
and i do think that sometimes the way
this conversation goes beyond the whole
her body her choice is a little bit too
one-sided as if men don't have feelings
in this matter and men don't want to be
fathers and men don't care about
you know when you abort that child
there's also the man present
who thinks about the fact that they
almost had a kid and that affects them
as well
so there has to be some consideration
for that portion too
and i think that's what's the most
shameful thing about this whole thing
but maybe not the most shameful most
important is that she reported a child
because of
astrology which is absolutely [ __ ]
crazy
that's astonishing it's astonishing but
but that's what happens when you buy
into astrology and you buy into it
enough
you start to believe in prejudiced ideas
you believe in these stupid things
right even though there's no proof for
it there's no evidence that it works
there's
none zero all the studies that have been
done have refuted
its existence in its work natal charts
whatever it is it's all
hocus pocus [ __ ] but when you
believe in magic for some people this is
a logical conclusion
you know if you really believe in
astrology the way she does right
you believe it it determines bonds it
determines this and that you know for
her she basically saw having this child
as like
having a child with a disability that's
how it was in her head this child is
going to become out less than ideal
we're not going to function they're
going to have a bad environment so
because of the astrology thing that i
believe in imma do this
that's where these kinds of ideologies
go for some people and it's
it's inevitable does that mean that
astrology should be wiped off the face
of the earth no i think if you want to
believe in mumbo jumbo go ahead
but it doesn't change the fact that it's
mumbo jumbo it's absolute nonsense
and you know this is where it goes and i
also think it's so um
so misguided of anyone going into
parenthood thinking like
they're supposed to be compatible or
good fit for their children that
it's supposed to be a good transition
news flash most parents will tell you
it's a very tumultuous period
there's a lot of ups and downs your
parents and jumped on children grew
detached from each other they reconnect
sometimes they don't get along sometimes
it's like oil and water
you know compatibility in you and a
child is not just a matter of
personality it's a matter of decisions
and effort
so you thinking the stars are going to
determine that
you got some holes in your game you're
already coming at this from a wrong
place
because i'll tell you this no matter how
different no matter how incompatible
what does that even mean really because
you're molding the child in a lot of
different ways
no matter how incompatible you guys
think you might be or how different
if you put in the effort if you try to
be present
if you really show love to that child
vast majority of time they're going to
respond in kind
even if they don't share your views and
all that they're gonna respond
so for you to give up because of a sign
[ __ ] you are
bugging bugging and
that is the meaning
of moving mad bro that that's crazy and
to the guy who's involved in this bro
leave if this is real if this is real
yeah
a hundred percent yeah yeah absolutely
if if it's real
absolutely because we never know believe
this man said he's sleeping on the couch
[ __ ] i'd be already out the door
done but this is also why i don't date
girls who believe in astrology mom and a
girl starts talking to me about mumbo
jumbo
and magic deuces so that's just my
thoughts on it
but hey y'all do you y'all live your
best life if you're moons and
sagittarius hope you guys have a good
time
in this retrograde gatorade blah blah
blah hope you enjoyed the video
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
oh
you